would you rather kill 25 kittens in a  row or one dog guys look driving down  the street if there's a litter of  kittens you're like  all at once come on a dog though oh i  don't have to kill any of these animals  okay i will chop up a cow and eat it for  dinner i will i'll go to ikea and i'll  eat the [ __ ] out of a horse [ __ ] meat  meatball i don't give a [ __ ]  well the ikea remember when they found  out there was horse meat in the ikea  things  and i still went back i'm like that's  why they're so good but i can't i look  at my dog and i do look at his little  chicken thighs  i like to conquer fears but i think it  would have to be a situation where the  person before they died in their will  was like i want annie letterman to eat  me i would maybe taste it i would maybe  taste it also because if i don't know i  don't care at all so that's the thing  too